no true true luck was the head of the
Department of Energy's intelligence
office during the investigation into
whether Los Alamos scientist when Holi
had given nuclear warhead secrets to
China codenamed kindred spirit is his
insider's account he spoke about it
recently in Washington DC for 40 minutes
welcome welcome to all of our guests
from the House and Senate to the to the
our regular national security issues
luncheon sponsored by the Hudson
Institute with the support of American
foundations and with congressman Dana
Rohrabacher as our congressional sponsor
for which we're very grateful I'm
pleased to see Paul Berkowitz here who
works with congressman Rohrabacher and I
thank him and bill Hawkins in the past
for the help in organizing these
discussions today I I'm going to mention
four themes that we're going to take up
and reverse order
the last theme will be something that
that we're going to look at next time in
our next monthly discussion but it
relates to a very important letter that
was released on March 5th by six members
of the House of Representatives to
Secretary of State Colin Powell and it
concerns the fact that the
democratically elected leader in
Venezuela has unfortunately become a
dictator and is working as a polkas has
violated the constitution of Venezuela
and also is supporting terrorists
attacking neighboring democratic
governments in this letter of March 5th
2003 calls upon the Secretary of State
to use articles 20 and 21 of the OAS
inter-american Democratic Charter to
bring an effort to begin an effort to
restore political democracy in Venezuela
we'll talk about that and the broader
pro-castro axis that's emerging in the
Americas that now in my judgment
includes 223 million people and there's
a short paper on that topic we'll talk
about that next time
the other issue we'll discuss briefly at
the end of artists our session is
winning the peace in Iraq and here
the concern is that the Iranian Shia
extremist regime has for years been
supporting hundreds of thousands of
Iranian rocky shear refugees and Iranian
territory and the risk that they will
seek to use the ten to forty thousand
armed Shia Iraqis from their territory
and political cadres to establish in
Iraq a second Iran that is a pro Iranian
Shia extremists regime after Saddam
Hussein has been removed this is a real
risk it's preventable I have a short
paper suggesting how to prevent it in
the essence of the idea is to help the
people of Iran 80% of whom oppose the
clerical regime replaced that with a
moderate constitutional government it is
possible after Saddam to have two
democracies in the region it's also
possible to have two iran's the other
topic we'll be discussing today with our
guest dr. alexander nimitz who is a
skilled scientist and Observer of
chinese and russian military technology
and trends and who's just done a very
important book on the russian military
sales and russian chinese military
cooperation he will be discussing china
russia and the crisis in north korea
that will follow the first event and
that's what i'm now going to present and
that is the very important issue of
Chinese nuclear espionage it's
appropriate that Dan feita who works
with congressman Christopher Cox is here
because we remember well in the Clinton
years that thanks to the courageous and
heroic efforts of the author of the book
we're discussing today kindred spirit
the story of Chinese nuclear espionage
mr. Newton autre true Locke thanks to
his efforts warnings were given to the
Clinton administration that China was
engaged in a massive effort to steal all
the nuclear weapons secrets of the
United States this book by mister true
Locke is dramatic it's inspiring it's it
is important he's an individual who has
worked for 30 years in the issue of an
and counterintelligence seized he was
one of the leaders in the early 90s in
looking into the issue of post-soviet
nuclear weapons and trying to reduce
their numbers and control them in the
former Soviet Union he did the first
work on this issue he is a part of the
important team an originator of the
nunn-lugar program the intellectual
shall we say contributor to that among
his many other contributions he has he
is an example mr. notes were true Locke
the author of kindred spirit inside
Chinese nuclear espionage is an example
of an individual who in the highest
tradition of American public service saw
a serious problem not being attended to
by the executive branch then the Clinton
administration went within channels to
higher and higher levels to get
attention to the issue finally got some
attention and of course we know the
results included the major scandal of
the espionage of dr. wen holy of Los
Alamos laboratories who the Clinton
administration FBI director and Justice
Department attorney general said had
stolen and taken from the Los Alamos
laboratories classified documents in all
50 years of nuclear weapons programs
equivalent in height to the size of the
Empire State Building and congressman
Christopher Cox leading a bipartisan
committee produced in 1998
extraordinarily important reports
documenting all the things that Mister
notary Trulock had warned about in the
early 1990s this book is the inside
story of Chinese nuclear espionage the
inside story of a dedicated public
official who does his duty to our
country and to the cause of peace and
freedom and also what happens when that
when it occurs I'm very pleased to
present mr. nutri Trulock
thank you dr. Mingus thank you all for
coming today as I have had the
opportunity to go back and look at what
I wrote in recent months sometimes I'm
struck by the fact that you know I if I
had not lived this story I'm not sure I
would believe it myself and but what I
want to focus on today are just three
basic aspects of sort of the overall
story and that is the the espionage
itself what happened how and why the
espionage was successful and then what
if anything was done about it during
this time some of you may know a man
named Paul Redmond Paul Redmond was in
1995 the senior-most counterintelligence
official at the CIA he's one of the
first people at CIA that we told about
all of what we had been discovering and
his first reaction was this case could
be as bad as the Rosenbergs he repeated
that for the New York Times in 1999 now
as some of you probably know this has
been widely dismissed scoffed at it has
become fashionable in places like the
Washington Post and elsewhere to Eve to
doubt whether espionage had occurred at
all but in fact by 1997 we were able to
document that the Chinese had been
conducting a 20-year assault on our
nuclear complex including the design
laboratories that stretched back well
into the late 1970s we had irrefutable
evidence that the Chinese had acquired
classified design information on two of
our nuclear warheads in the 1980s the
enhanced radiation warhead is known as
the neutron bomb and the w88 or had the
most modern thermonuclear warhead in the
world we know that they had acquired
classified information on five more
nuclear warheads all of them intended
for ballistic missiles we were later to
learn that a Los Alamos scientist had
compromised
another 22 nuclear warheads by
transferring files containing classified
information designs shapes geometries
dimensions and so forth out onto an
unprotected
network server down at Los Alamos
National Laboratory in just one
eight-month period from 1997 to 1998 324
attacks on that network server were
recorded most of them successful we know
that he also placed on portable magnetic
tapes all of this information he made 20
tapes those 20 tapes have never been
recovered by 1997 we knew that the
Chinese were also after the tools that
the laboratories were developing to help
us assure reliability and safety of our
warheads without resort to nuclear
testing nuclear codes simulation tools
and particularly data from the 1,000 US
nuclear tests that we had done over time
and that same Los Alamos scientists
loaded all of those files out onto the
network server at Los Alamos now it is
absolutely true that we don't know what
specifically the Chinese got we don't
know specifically if they got blueprints
or what our intelligence frankly is just
not that good but I would remind you
that it took us 40 years and the fall of
the Soviet Union to learn how deeply the
Soviets had penetrated the Manhattan
Project and in my view if you're playing
you bet your country it might be prudent
to assume the worst with regard to the
Chinese acquisitions whatever the case
in the year 2000 a federal prosecutor
did a retrospective study on this and he
wrote this represents one of the gravest
and most consequential purported acts of
espionage ever investigated by the FBI
so how did all this happen why did it
happen I mean no one should be surprised
that China Russia and others are
conducting espionage against our nuclear
laboratories it's the second oldest
profession after all but why was it
successful
my focus was on the Energy Department
and its nuclear laboratories and what we
found as we began to dig into this were
two decades of warning
from CIA and FBI and others to the
Energy Department about the
vulnerability of its laboratories to
nuclear espionage we found in the files
for example a CIA document from 1985
specifically warning the new Los Alamos
director about their vulnerability of
his laboratories and the risk that he
was running by permitting Chinese
scientists to come in and visit those
warnings continued right up to 1996 and
1997 and I think the best way to
characterize the labs reaction to this
comes in the conclusion of a study done
by the president's foreign intelligence
advisory board a blue-ribbon Commission
they termed the attitude of the labs and
the energy department towards this
threat to be pollyannish quote pradhan
the predominant attitude towards
security and counterintelligence among
many do ii and lab managers has ranged
from half-hearted grudging accommodation
to smug disregard and i would say
there's no better measure of that than
the response by the energy department
and the laboratories to efforts to
reform security and counterintelligence
that began in 1996 we undertook this job
in earnest in in good faith but for two
years the energy department dragged its
feet obstructed our efforts to work this
problem to the to the point that i had
to go outside of the department to the
national security council and involve
the national security council and the
internal counterintelligence bureaucracy
of the federal government that is to say
CIA FBI DOD and elsewhere they came in
did yet another study came to the same
conclusions that all of the previous
studies had come to made a series of
recommendations none of which were
implemented by the energy department and
all of that led up to the signing of a
presidential decision directive by
president clinton
in early 1998 now does anyone know of a
PDD or any kind of national security
directive like this that is only
targeted to one agency and in most of
these cut across to agencies they are in
ten
to coordinate all the activities of the
government in this case the President
himself had to direct the Energy
Department to implement effective
counterintelligence reform
and yet the Energy Department and its
laboratories slow rolled and delayed
this reform for another year
beyond 1998 and again the blue-ribbon
panel concluded when it looked at this
never before has the panel found an
agency with the bureaucratic insolence
to dispute delay or resist
implementation of a presidential
decision directive on security as do E's
bureaucracy tried to do two PDD 61 and
what about the FBI's conduct of an
investigation as grave as and and
consequential has the kindred spirit
investigation the whodunit phase of
kindred spirit began in late 1995 the
FBI refused our initial request to take
up the Espionage their response was the
trail is too old it's too cold so they
asked us to do a preliminary inquiry
looking just at the energy department
laboratory starting from a population of
about one hundred and fifty five
thousand when doing it down using a set
of filters including access to the w8
w88 information travel to China
interactions with Chinese scientists at
their home and also security anomalies
after about six months we had identified
12 potential investigative leads and we
handed these leads over to the FBI in
May of 1996 now we also warned the FBI
not just to look at the D UE
laboratories they had to go out and look
at the defense contractors as well that
defense contractors responsible for
building for example the re-entry
vehicle for the defy system but it's
clear to us in retrospect that the FBI
never did that
and in fact the FBI immediately
discarded ten of those leads and focused
exclusively on that Los Alamos scientist
dr. Wynn wholly at the time this was to
me inexplicable I could not understand
why it was the FBI was focusing
exclusively on dr. Lee but it turns out
of course that the bureau had in the
words of director fre when he testified
about this in the year 2000 a long
history with Wynn Olie dating well back
to 1982
I learned in the preparation of this
book that in 1996 when the FBI opened a
full field counterintelligence
investigation of dr. Lee that was the
third time that Lee had been the subject
of an FBI counterintelligence
investigation since 1982 and in 1984 as
a result of the first interactions with
the FBI
a lab security director at Los Alamos
had recommended his termination way back
in 1984 and that recommendation was
ignored and it went on from there here's
the bottom line on wynn holy and this
comes from a federal prosecutor who
looked at this in retrospect in the year
2000 looking at all of the
circumstantial evidence that had been
built up over time he concluded that
there was sufficient probable cause to
believe that when holy was an agent of a
foreign power that is to say a u.s.
person currently engaged in clandestine
intelligence gathering activities for or
on behalf of the PRC now given all this
you might expect that the FBI would have
conducted a very vigorous very
aggressive investigation into this and
I'm here to tell you today that their
investigation was anything but vigorous
and aggressive and in fact they did next
to nothing for three years 1996 until
1999 the investigation was run out of
the Albuquerque field office but I
learned in the preparation this book
that the FBI working from Albuquerque
never worked on this case full-time it
never assigned agents even one agent
to the case full-time that in fact it
was on the bottom of the list of the off
of the field offices priorities the
field office had four major priorities
counterespionage was the last priority
on the list and the win wholly kindred
spirit case was the very last priority
in that list agents were sent down to
Albuquerque to work on this and they
were immediately diverted to other tasks
like Indian Reservation crime and even
doing background checks on scientists I
learned that the FBI never conducted
surveillance on dr. Lee of any kind
physical surveillance electronic
surveillance and they never bothered to
look at his computer activities they
never interviewed his supervisors or his
co-workers and they really never knew
just what it was that when Holi was
working on they never reviewed his work
product classified or otherwise they
were the field office was directed from
headquarters to do a trash cover on dr.
Lee trash cover looking at his trash the
the kind of thing that was used against
Aldrich Ames for example but the
Albuquerque office refused to do that
they never did a financial analysis of
dr. Lee they even had gone as far has
obtained an attorney general approval to
do this but before they got around to it
the approval lapsed and they never
bothered to go back and renew it so I
had to explain all this yeah I it's
inexplicable to me I can only offer two
possible reasons clearly within the
Justice Department at that time there
was a fear of offending the government
of China internal bureau documents show
that efforts to open a bureau office in
Beijing a legal attache Lee gas actually
impeded the bureau's investigation into
Chinese nuclear espionage and kindred
spirit is not the only example of DOJ
and the bureau's unwillingness to
prosecute if the potential for
embarrassment to China existed and I
would refer you to a case that was run
in 1997 on her scientist named Peter Lee
no relation to win wholly he had been
under investigation under observation by
the FBI for years things came to a head
when the assistant you
best attorney in Los Alamos excuse me in
Los Angeles wanted to prosecute him on
espionage charges he was blocked from
doing that by Justice Department by main
justice back here main justice had him
wait to indict Peter Lee until after a
Chinese US presidential summit held here
in Washington in 1997 and eventually
they also blocked him from indicted
earlier on espionage charges Lee had
attempted to obstruct justice in this
case but the DOJ ignored that too and
they ended up finding him $20,000 and he
spent a year in a halfway house in
Anaheim you know the message to me that
comes out of this is if you get caught
spying for China in the Clinton
administration you're gonna get a free
pass basically but there's also a second
that to me is a more disturbing reason I
think behind this now recall that
director fre said that the bureau had a
long history with Wynn wholly I learned
in 1999 that dr. Lee and his wife had in
fact been recruited by the FBI to become
informational assets way back in 1984
and it was that action that probably
saved dr. Lee's job the first time when
the security director recommended that
he be fired and so for the next seven
years the Lee's would travel to China to
meet senior Chinese nuclear weapons
experts they would entertain these
experts in their homes outside of Los
Alamos and all the time the FBI was
picking up the tab for this - its
chagrin the FBI learned in 1984 however
that on those visits dr. Lee had been
helping Chinese nuclear scientists
improve their computer codes and he
later was to admit that he was using
information from the classified codes
that he had been working on in
developing down at Los Alamos and he was
also meeting with very senior Chinese
nuclear scientists and then not
reporting those meetings when he
returned or the topics of discussions
that he was having with these
individuals in so tell him when he came
back that has led many and not just me
but many inside Washington to believe
that the Lee's in fact doubled the FBI
during this period and so you can
imagine the embarrassment to the bureau
and therefore the links to which the
bureau would go to cover all that up
and the links began started to become
clear in 1999 as the bureau basically
sought the scapegoat energy for its own
failures that effort here began in the
midst of the [ __ ] Committee hearings
was essentially to fend off criticism of
its own performance although it never
really explained why it had done
practically nothing for three years and
this of course became especially
critical when the bureau learned
belatedly the dr. Lee had been creating
his own nuclear files on an unclassified
network for more than a decade that in
1997 for example after he was under
investigation and after the FBI had
directed us to leave him in place in an
on alert status
when wholly created a tape that included
the very latest data on the w88 and
detailed design information on both the
primary and the secondary of another of
our nuclear warheads inevitably the the
campaign became very personal in 1999
the some of you know the FBI eventually
came into my town house seized my
personal computer without a search
warrant
at the same time it also targeted some
of my supporters up here on Capitol Hill
the FBI visited offices particularly on
the Senate side demanding to examine
their computers supposed to be looking
for emails that I had sent them I would
note that these were all Republicans I
sense of wish that I'd send some to
Democrats as well and they began a
whispering campaign sought to blacklist
me I was never charged with anything
by the way I was told finally in the
year 2001 that I was no longer of
interest to the bureau I'd heard that
term before when they started throwing
it around recently but of course the
damage to my professional predator and
personal reputation was already done and
then so I was to recall many times
during this that old Washington saying
that no good deed goes unpunished
in Washington so let me just wrap it up
here with a couple of thoughts I've had
about with regard to implications now
one of the upsides of this has to do
with the reform of counterintelligence
at the Energy Department it is true that
energy finally does have the resources
necessary to conduct an effective
counterintelligence program and I'm told
that there are 87 P
in the CI office back here in
headquarters that's probably more than
our actually out in the field which
seems to me to have the whole thing
backwards but the most recent Los Alamos
scandal involving misappropriations of
fun but also the the security
implications of that and continuing
problems managing the presence of
foreign national scientists including
those from Iran and elsewhere raises
concerns at least on my part that the
fixes that we have seen are primarily
cosmetic I think the larger issue here
is my impression is that there is a
consensus within government that our
national counterintelligence effort is
badly broken and that we may not yet
have the capability to effectively
protect against the threat from foreign
intelligence services secondly of course
is this unresolved debate going on over
China for me as an intelligence officer
that was a question really the larger
question for policy makers to decide I
would just say that in the meantime I
think we need to think very hard about
protecting against the transfers of our
strategic technologies and expertise to
the Chinese and then finally I would
just wrap up by saying that to me the
way that the national security
bureaucracy handled the kindred spirit
case in many ways foreshadowed what
happened on 9/11 clearly there was a it
can't happen here mentality that
pervaded the bureaucracy there were all
sorts of real and imagined constraints
on the use of critical FBI tools like
the FISA the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act against dr. Winn wholly
that we saw repeated in that case and I
would just urge that we desperately need
to learn and understand the lessons of
the kindred spirit case to make sure
that we guard against repeat behaviors
so thank you I'll stop there and take
any questions
[Applause]
after all these events took place when
Holi and some of his supporters were
saying racial profiling and talking
about bringing suits I mean my view at
the time was if I wanted to find out
where the IRA did fundraising in the
states I wouldn't go to a Chinese
restaurant I'd go to an Irish bar so I
mean the the fact that someone might be
the ethnic Chinese and might be
considered a potential espionage agent
for China is not surprising to me but
whatever happened with that wear suits
ever broader did that die I think I
think the lawsuits are still pending on
that I know they've sued the government
with regard to privacy look that that
was part of dr. Lee's defense strategy
to get him off basically you know and
one of the one of the aspects of it was
to play the race card to allege that he
had been racially ethnically profiled
pure and simple it never happened Lee
was on the list has were the other 12
people on the list because of access to
the w88 opportunity traveled back and
forth and also problems and anomalies
that we found in their security lists
and their security files and of course
later when the Justice Department did a
review they concluded that that these
allegations of racism ethnic profiling
had no merit whatsoever but you throw it
out in the media and perhaps it'll stick
other questions after nuclear secrets
may be shifted to the institutions of
feed into the National Laboratories in
the sense that they Burma d-y their
fault if well you know I look I've been
out of the government you know since 99
year 2000 and my perception and from
what I hear inside is they are still
very active against the laboratories
clearly the institutions that feed the
laboratories like the University of
California and elsewhere that does
provide a conduit in many of the the
postdocs and so forth come from China
come from the weapons program in China
into the UC
work and then are fed in to Los Alamos
itself and we were aware of this even at
the time we could see this process
ongoing still going on today as far as I
knew others please there's been have
been the scope of your work but if we
know that the the PRC obtained our
nuclear secrets and such is there any
evidence that they then transferred
those on to the highest bidder or do any
other bidders that's an excellent
question you know and and one I get
asked a lot and and the bottom line is
our intelligence as far as I know and
certainly by 99 when I left we we could
not show one way or the other
what concerns me is the relationship of
China to Pakistan Pakistan is a nuclear
state today because of China and then
the relationship between Pakistan and
Korea you know a North Korea helping
them with their uranium enrichment and
so who knows what kind of information is
in that is in that triangle missile
technology to Iran Iraq North Korea etc
and so I'd imagine that there may be
some kind of link from our technology to
all this then another broader question
for you mr. Trulock um you mentioned the
the postgraduate students who
essentially come in under I guess under
orders from their host countries weapons
programs how would you recommend vetting
or how would you recommend defending
against that international laboratories
yeah vetting in the first place would be
welcomed yeah I mean we had always
proposed that there be background checks
done there be counterintelligence agency
checks the laboratories had pretty much
waived that off by 1994-1995
so we sought to reinstitute that process
we found that the management of the
program at places like Los Alamos was so
sloppy that a postdoc would come in he
would meet with his sponsor and then for
two years he would they'd never see each
other again so the sponsor had no idea
where the PO
stocke was what he was doing he was
roaming around the laboratory someplace
now what's really worrisome about this
is there is there has been a recent
Inspector General report done by the
Energy Department looking at the foreign
visits and assignments program again and
what they found was regrettably it
appears that everything has slipped back
to what it was they cited a couple of
examples at Brookhaven National
Laboratory up on Long Island they found
an Iranian scientist from Iran on the
state-sponsored terrorism list but the
laboratory had not obtained the
secretary approvals that are required
had not done the background checks had
not done a counterintelligence check
they had even bothered to check to see
if the Iranian had a valid passport or a
current visa and that sort of thing was
also going on down at Los Alamos so as I
say it appears to me the things that
pretty much snapped back to where they
were when all this started please I was
formerly when some of this was going on
the visa chief and in Beijing and I just
was gonna come a new thing I know there
were a lot of people coming through
going for either academic or other
exchange visitor reasons involved in
technology and the old procedure before
9/11 I think it's now called visa mantas
where you check people on a technology
transfer is you would wait 10 working
days than if you got no answer the visa
would be issued now everyone knows in
Washington and take ten days to have all
these different agencies check a
person's name it's not likely you'd get
a response but the the the upside for
that was no one had to take
responsibility later if something turned
up because there was no one no Inferno
directive coming back from Washington
issue this visa where someone had said
this person was clean now after 9/11 and
I understand it's caused some concern in
the US business community in China with
different exchanges but now you cannot
issue the visa until there's a response
from Washington saying okay well of
course that requires someone taking
responsibility if they're not okay
and so it's very very slow process now I
mean we're talking about four months six
months and as I know some of these
involve business contracts and there's
like concern in the American business
community although they want to be
patriotic but the point shows when you
put somebody on the line and they have
to take responsibility to say somebody's
okay they're gonna be very careful about
as opposed to just ten days and you hear
nothing and go ahead and let them go off
to the US right and our experience the
the labs also complained about the time
required to do all the background checks
but we found that when you know when we
actually focused on this and got the
feds working on this we could turn a
background check or a CI check in 48
hours
oh yeah so it's not an insurmountable
obstacle at that time
the weapons and we've looked at the
weapons of mass destruction in North
Korea Iran Iraq from of the unclassified
government sources and other indicators
and of course this is one of our
nation's highest priorities that we
stopped the proliferation and spread of
these deadly weapons and ballistic
missile components therefore it's
remarkable to me to hear from you since
we're about to engage in a major
military operation in part to stop
proliferation that that we still are so
poorly staffed to do this right here at
home where we can make a big difference
if you were now put in charge of doing
this what would you do to improve
counterintelligence I mean what I think
you talk about a bridge too far well at
least in the Energy Department I am
astonished that there are 87 people here
in headquarters and I would bet that's
four or five times the number of people
that are actually on the field where the
rubber meets the road
you know the emphasis of the reform
programs that we pushed was the complete
opposite we wanted professional
counterintelligence experts working at
the laboratories and senior retired FBI
and so forth we also wanted and needed
and you've got to have this you've got
to have buy-in from the very top the
scientists the lab managers have to know
that this is a priority for Washington
they have to know it's a priority for
the leadership in the Energy Department
they have to know it's a priority from
the White House and you could see when
when in 98 1998 when the President of
the United States mandates a
counterintelligence program and yet the
laboratories obstruct and holdup and
delay and so forth I mean that gives you
some sense of the of the kind of problem
you're encountering here so you know
professionalize the staff give them the
resources they need and above all things
make sure that you have management
support up to to the very highest levels
and the last thing I would argue is at
some point in this system you've got to
have some accountability there is simply
no accountability at the Energy
Department there are people in energy
today holding very high positions that I
witnessed lying under
to the Congress during testimony in 1999
the one of the culprits one of the you
know people that retrospective studies
have sort of most singled out as being
responsible for not informing his
superiors at the bureau of how badly
things were going on in Albuquerque is
now the director of counterintelligence
at the Energy Department so until you
until you find a way to eradicate that
culture I don't have much hope directly
here right here in the US Capitol right
here in the US Congress building right
here in the city and many of our cities
I would believe this would be a high
priority for President Bush if he knew
about it do you think he has a feeling
for this and how do we help him
understand decision to giving him a copy
of Kingsborough well yeah but I you know
again I've had no opportunity to
interact with anyone from the
administration on this issue and
regrettably I would say I would think I
would agree with you I would think it
would be one of the highest priorities
but he has lots of things on his plate
right now
structures at EoE the laboratories are
fiefdom zhun to themselves they bristle
and fiercely resist any effort from
Washington to impose any kind of
controls management accountability
responsibility on them they believe that
they are entities unto themselves and of
course they can always when things get
bad run to their patrons up here on
Capitol Hill
I mean woe to any manager at the Energy
Department in the 90s at least during my
time to try to enforce any of the rules
or any sort of accountability on the
laboratories because you were sure to
get a phone call and a summons from
someone up here and you'd be in their
office the next morning explaining why
it was that you were interfering with
you know the conduct of all this
wonderful science going on
there and how this was creating you know
brain drain and we were deterring you
know some of our best minds in the
country from coming to these
laboratories it's a it's a protection
racket that goes on and most managers
you know will just say okay and go with
the flow
I don't know quite how much
organizational problems play into this
and I'm not a hundred percent sure if I
want to talk to organization about
organization but what is your opinion
many people criticize the FBI it has a
sort of cops-and-robbers quote unquote
approach to counterintelligence where US
data advocates separation of
counterintelligence from most of the FBI
it into a separate agency that could
pass a sort of holistic analytical view
of counterintelligence I'm persuaded
that that is an option that ought to be
examined that what I have seen what I
experienced Lu I didn't even see the
cops and robbers part of CIA in the wind
only case I am persuaded that
particularly given the importance of
analysis you know an analytic work and
the fact that the FBI
you know just seems institutionally not
to be able to do that I think I would
support an alternative like that pulling
it out creating some sort of National
counterintelligence executive sir
equation made by by Marcos so maybe
maybe really it's the time to divide the
counterintelligence divisions out of FBI
because I have my own experience I
especially visited FBI Bureau in
Minneapolis to speak about the role of
Russian intelligence and what I heard
they even didn't want to speak to me and
very bad impression
now I thought at this moment that it is
only the case in Minneapolis but now but
it seems that the situation with
counterintelligence is bad all over
America so so it shouldn't please maybe
maybe it's really the task of the
supreme importance to establish separate
counterintelligence organization I mean
to back up what we found in 1995 when we
started on this was that many of the
best people on Chinese espionage at the
bureau had already left that the
sections devoted to counter espionage at
the bureau had been steadily dismantled
in
in the past three years beginning in the
early 90s accelerating in 93 94 and many
of the best people had gone ray Wycombe
for example came to work for me at the
energy department one of the best people
over there and driven out to no interest
so it was in a sense purposeful I think
to take down that capability yes thank
you for attention
no true true luck is currently associate
editor of the accuracy and media report
codenamed kindred spirit is published by
encounter books on the web ed encounter
books calm